tombé au champ d'honneur les premiers
chaîne qui serviront la reconstruction
de la flèche de notre dame de paris
commence à être abattu plus de 300
arbres rien qu'en centre val de loire
chez nous la première découpe avait lieu
aujourd'hui au domaine de montpoupon
pour les propriétaires la fierté de
contribuer à la reconstruction d'un des
plus beaux monuments de france paul
boyer avec audrey champigny pour choisir
les plus beaux chênes du domaine de
montpoupon il faut s'armer de patience
c'est dans cette forêt de plus de 1000
hectares que vont être choisis cinq
chaînes pour aider à la reconstruction
de la flèche de notre dame une fois
l'arbre identifiés placent au marquage
celui ci il est très très droit jusqu'à
la découpe un petit peu claires pour la
course aux points de vue qualité il
correspond tout à fait à un critère de
charpente aujourd'hui c'est l'heure
d'abattre ces arbres didier guillaume
duval bûcheron de père en fils sont
chargés de la découpe
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre
l'abattage doit se faire avant la montée
de la sève ils ont abattu un des arbres
qui a été sélectionné
là en ce moment ils sont en train de
couper les branches et de le parer pour
qu'il soit prêt par la suite des bardes
et avant qu'il soit pris par un camion à
quelques centaines de mètres de là le
deuxième arbre pose problème fondu à
l'extérieur la découpe doit être
parfaite afin de ne pas le rendre
complètement alors il faut chausser pour
éviter de ne pas éclater la bille
jusqu'au pire si ça prend dans un hôte
armes comme ça des fois ils vont
tellement s'appelle centre jusqu'aux
pieds après sir inutilisable mission
accomplie tout au long de la matinée
cinq chaînes sont abattus pour le plus
grand bonheur du propriétaire du domaine
en tant que propriétaire d'un monument
historique le trouve ça fantastique de
pouvoir avant un arbre à chartres et à
notre dame
en plus ces bois ont été plantés ici par
mon arrière grand père donc c'est
quelque chose que j'aime tient à coeur
comme lui des dizaines de propriétaires
de forêts privées ont accepté de faire
don de leurs plus beaux arbres en tout
un peu plus de 1000 chaînes dont 300
centre val de loire seront offerts par
les propriétaires forestiers